AMIT GANDHI: Hi.
My name is Amit Gandhi.
And I'm a graduate
researcher at MIT.
Welcome to the
series on exploring
fairness and machine learning
for international development.
In this module, we will cover
the appropriate usage framework
developed by the US Agency
for International Development.
The Center for Digital
Development at USAID
has been studying the
appropriate use of machine
learning and developing
country contexts.
Among other activities,
this research
is involved engaging
stakeholders, conducting
case studies, and developing and
publishing and appropriate use
framework.
The work done by
the MIT CITE team
builds on certain aspects
of this report, which can be
found in the linked materials.
In this section, we will be
presenting some characteristics
for the appropriate application
of machine learning.
Please keep these
characteristics in mind
as you think about the
projects you were working with.
They are intended to
help practitioners think
through the ethical and
appropriate use of machine
learning in international
development.
The first criterion
is relevance.
Is the use of machine
learning in this context
solving an appropriate problem?
As machine learning
becomes more of a trend,
we are seeing more
and more organizations
seeking to apply
it to their work
in an effort to
distinguish themselves
from their competitors
or to increase
their appeal to funders.
Many of these
organizations may try
to implement prepackaged or
off the shelf machine learning
solutions without
understanding if it
is the right tool
for the problem they
are trying to solve.
For an example of relevance,
let us consider the tracking
of human assistance delivery.
Organizations may want to
create systems to monitor people
in refugee camps and
make sure they're only
getting the food
or other supplies
that they're entitled to.
However, the major losses
often happen further upstream,
such as people diverting
whole trucks full of supplies,
not individuals taking two
bags of rice instead of one.
An AI solution to keep a
closer eye on individual aid
recipients would fail
the relevancy test
because it is not addressing
a major issue in the system.
The second criterion
is representativeness.
Is the data used to train
the machine learning
models appropriately selected?
In order to evaluate
representativeness,
the organization should
consider if the machine learning
model uses data representative
to the context in which it will
be deployed and
which strategies are
important for
ensuring models can be
trained with appropriate data.
As an example, consider a
startup medical diagnostics
company that is trying to
build a remote diagnostic tool
for the West African population.
High quality coded data
sets from West Africa
may not be available.
So the startup uses a European
data set to train their models.
Some diagnoses may be accurate,
but disease differences
between Europe and
West Africa may
cause misdiagnoses
for individuals,
putting them at health risk.
Now consider if the
startup used a data set
based on East African
patient data instead
of European patient data.
While this would probably
provide better results,
resulting diagnoses
from this model
would overlook diseases such as
malaria and yellow fever, which
tend to be more
common in West Africa,
and also result in
improper diagnosis.
Finally, let's
consider if the startup
uses a data set from patients
from the largest hospitals
in West African countries.
While this may seem like
a good choice at first,
this data set would
probably be more
representative of
urban populations
as compared to
rural populations,
also resulting in
improper diagnosis.
This example shows that there
can be different scales of data
representation and
that coders need
to be careful tests
right questions
about the context
for each problem
to design models appropriately.
The third criterion is value.
Does the machine
learning model produce
predictions that
are more accurate
than alternative methods?
Does it explain
variation more completely
than alternative models?
Do the predicted values
inform human decisions
in a meaningful way?
For example, are
they actionable?
Telling farmers that they
could improve their yields
by moving to a
different elevation
is not useful to them.
Are they timely?
Having information but not
enough time to act on it
provides little to no value.
Are they delivered
to the right people?
You shouldn't build a system
that provides information
to frontline workers
when decisions
are made by their supervisors.
While machine learning
is a powerful tool,
it is not always the best
approach to all problems.
Organizations should
have sufficient reason
to think that machine learning
would add value and make sure
that they evaluate that
assumption before scaling
solutions.
The fourth criterion
is explainability.
How effectively is the use of
machine learning communicated?
It is important to ensure that
the application is explained
to end users in a way that
is effectively communicating
how outcomes were determined.
Organizations seeking to apply
machine learning outcomes
without understanding
the nuances of how
models make decisions
may use algorithm outputs
inappropriately.
Let's look back at the
earlier example of gender
differentiated credit scoring
in the previous module.
An explainable solution
could include information
on why a specific
individual was denied a loan
and which factors they
could change in order
for them to increase
their credit worthiness.
The fifth criterion
is auditability.
Can the models decision
making processes
be queried or monitored
by external actors?
Increasingly, organizations
returning to black box machine
learning solutions, whose
inner workings can range from
unintuitive to incomprehensible.
It is important that the outputs
can be monitored externally
to show that the model
is fair, unbiased,
and does not harm some users.
This may require
additional infrastructure,
whether it is institutional
or legal frameworks that
require audits, provide
auditors with secure access
to data and algorithms,
and require people
to act on those findings.
The sixth criterion is equity.
If used to guide
decision making,
has the machine
learning model been
tested to determine whether
it is disproportionately
harmful or beneficial to
some individuals or groups
more than others?
Testing the results
of algorithms
against protected variables,
such as gender, age, race,
or skin color, is key to
preventing the adoption
of biased algorithms.
Does a specific algorithm
fail for specific groups
more often than it does
for other groups of people?
Does it misclassified different
groups in different directions?
Or did certain groups
have different rates
of false positives
or false negatives?
It is also important
to address the issue
that accuracy and fairness are
not necessarily correlated.
Algorithms can be accurate
technically but still
inconsistent with the values
that the organizations may
want to promote when making
decisions, such as who should
be hired, who should
receive medical care,
or other similar decisions.
Gaining an understanding of
how these outcomes are derived
and taking steps
to mitigate them
is an important
piece in ensuring
that unfair algorithms are
not widely adopted and used.
The seventh criterion
is accountability
or responsibility.
If used to guide
decision making,
are there mechanisms
in place to ensure
that someone will be
responsible for responding
to feedback and redress
harms, if necessary?
For example, an
algorithm might be
used to assist in diagnosing
medical conditions.
But the final diagnosis should
be still provided by a trained
medical professional.
When used by itself, the risk
from false identifications
from the algorithm can actually
cause harm to individuals.
However, consider if there
is a shortage of trained
medical professionals.
Does the risk of misdiagnoses
outweigh the risk
of not treating people?
These decisions are complicated,
and there is not always
a right answer.
It is important to
keep accountability
and responsibility in mind
when designing systems.
Remember, an accountable
setup both make sure
that there are systems in
place to prevent harmful errors
and make sure someone is
responsible for correcting
errors.
As a review, we talked
about seven characteristics
for the appropriate
application of machine
learning in this module.
The first is relevance.
The second is
representativeness.
The third is value.
The fourth is explainability.
The fifth is auditability.
The sixth is equity.
And the seventh
is accountability
and responsibility.
Be sure to take this
into consideration
while you're implementing
your own solutions.
Thank you for taking the
time to take this course.
We hope that you'll
continue to watch the rest
of the modules in this series.
[MUSIC PLAYING]